so let's have a look at this first puppy
here and if you are just loading up you
know maybe actually if you haven't got
your PDF just just hit pause it's okay
all the information that you need is in
front of you on the screen let's just
have a look at this one question now
what do we use or how do we use I should
say the fundamental theorem of calculus
to answer this question well I'm going
to say look that 2x in there that's the
FX that I'm now going to find the
primitive of what's the function that
when I differentiate it gives me that
okay so I'm gonna have to reverse
everything that I knew from
differentiation to integrate this I'm
going to put in my square brackets to
indicate the thing inside is my
primitive function and hopefully some of
you are following along and you know
what the primitive of 2x is it's going
to be the x squared right
I feel like Dora the Explorer which is
like hey everyone where would you like
to go and she's just like talking to a
silent camera she's not even a real
character anyway what am I talking about
now you get your x squared there that's
the primitive but we're not finished yet
we have to have our lower in our upper
bounds 1 and 4 on the outside there and
what they indicate is I'm going to
evaluate at the endpoint which is 4 and
I'm going to subtract that from
evaluating the start point which is 1 so
that's going to look like this 4 squared
take away 1 squared so if you go back to
the fundamental theorem of calculus that
you put a big box around this is the F
of B take away the F of a that's the
part that I'm evaluating here now I know
a lot of you will be like Lal I don't
need to write 4 squared + 1 squared I
know what those are equal to that's fine
but I'm just going to say to you right
now this substitution step is going to
save you a lot in the future we we're
obviously not going to be dealing with
just simple functions like this
sometimes they're quite terrible and
messy and if you get something wrong and
you just simplify it in your head and
you write down the number like say 16 or
1 and if you get that incorrect you have
no way to work out what's going wrong
because you're like I don't know there's
just the number there is it correct or
not I've just got to do the question all
over again so even though 4 squared is a
value I know and you know I'm going to
write 4 squared down anyway then I'm
going to actually simplify that
I get a number at the end now at this
point here I will ask all of you to have
a quick look at the textbook and I'll
even pull it up here is my answers where
I was checking things or at page do I
need to be on I think is around 23 isn't
it
twenty-three twenty-two all right here
we go
No at this point we do actually need to
quickly look at the question because the
questions wording is very important to
us it says evaluate the following
definite integrals using the fundamental
theorem now this is important that we've
read this carefully because when we had
a look at the questions that mrs. Lee's
gave to us before they were all cached
in terms of area now we can use area to
verify that this answer 15 is correct
let me show you I've graph this guy
already here this is 2x and I'm having a
look at it from 1 all the way over to 4
and I can actually quickly verify that
the answer of 15 does make sense let's
do a similar kind of approach to how
mrs. Lee's did it before I can break
this up into a rectangle I've
conveniently made all of the squares
unit squares so there's 1 2 3 4 5 6 so
there's the area of your rectangle down
the bottom when I have a look at a
triangle on the top you can see that the
width of it is 3 the height of it is
it's Catholic 1 2 3 4 5 6
haider 6 so base times height on 2 is 18
on 2 so it gives me an area of 9 9 plus
6 gives me the 15 that I saw before but
if I just come back to this original
question now this answer of 15 is not 15
units squared it's not an area have a
look at the question it just says
evaluate an integral that's just a
number often that number is useful to
work out an area and we can use an area
to help us work out the number but the
actual definite integral itself is just
the number 15 so that's it we're done
now this guy here I picked this one as
an example because we could verify it
very simply with an area because you end
up with something nice and neat a
rectangle across a top a triangle or all
the way around
you could done the trapezium formula for
this too but it doesn't take long before
you start looking at things where you
like I have no idea what kind of formula
I should
there's no other choice but to use
calculus here so let's have a go at this
one it's 4e we're just going to continue
to working directly underneath now just
like before I'm gonna use the
fundamental theorem by first saying I
need to know what the primitive function
is of this guy in here 4x cubed plus 5
that's um called the integrand by the
way if you're looking for the technical
term wrong color this guy here is called
the integrand now they've given us
pretty easy numbers for this first part
of the exercise 4x cubed
what is the primitive function of just
that part of it that's going to be X to
the power of 4 right did you say 42 your
screen thank you Hamza okay wonderful
very proud of you X to the power of 4
that's the first part I've got a plus 5
that's even easier to integrate it's
just gonna be Thank You Eddie you beat
me to the punch
5 X so that's the whole primitive and
now I'm going to evaluate it from
negative 1 up to 2 now I picked out this
particular example because these
negative numbers they're going to come
up a lot and because we already have
subtraction happening inside these
brackets you're just asking for problems
if you don't be careful with where your
brackets are where you evaluate things
like I said this is why that
substitution step is so useful let's do
that right now
I'm going to do the the upper bound and
then I'm going to subtract that from the
lower bounce so what have I got here
I've got X to the power 4 that's 2 to
the power 4 plus 5 lots of - that's my F
of B if you like and I'll subtract that
from F of a and maybe some of you
already ahead of me and have actually
evaluated this already
there's my F of B on the left hand side
my F of a on the right hand side and now
I actually know these numbers I
encourage you by the way at this point
do not rely on your calculator come on
use your brain there that's not by the
way that's not just me being mean it is
also a really important way to keep on
having those arithmetic muscles fresh
you'll be so much better at actually
identifying problems and errors in your
own working if you can look at it rather
than relying on a calculator so - the 4
is 16
five lots of two is ten I'm going to
subtract negative one multiplied by
itself four Lots that's one and then I'm
gonna add negative five
that gives me twenty six on the left
hand side I'm subtracting okay careful
here one plus negative five one plus
negative 5 that's negative 4 right and
then when I have those double negatives
I'm gonna get 26 plus 4 which is 13
okay now I'm sort of a little nervous
I'm looking at the comments I'm
wondering if anyone's got there I
thought I saw a 20 before but maybe
someone deleted that because I can't
find it anymore do I get some agreement
can I get some thumbs up some Happy's
unhappy x' what do you guys reckon Thank
You Rahul fantastic Kevin much
appreciated
okay happy times so a quick note some
people I think I think someone said
something about the the plus C where'd
that go right this constant of
integration right why doesn't it appear
and I see mrs. Lee's has already put it
in there so in case you can't quite see
that there in her comments if I were to
put the plus C in here let's actually
put it where we normally would which is
when we integrate there's the constant
of integration okay
what will happen is when I do my F of B
and my F of a you might notice that plus
C appears in both of them the plus C as
a constant it's independent of X so when
x equals negative 1 C you still see and
when X is equal to 2 C is still C so
you're you can see that the plus C here
and the plus C here they're just gonna
cancel out right and you can see that
again and this is leaves very carefully
written out working so we get an answer
of 30 all right happy times I was a
little more involved but again I
actually reckon the Devils in the
details here the calculus is often not
the hard part that was the easy part of
the beginning you're like oh X to the 4
plus 5 X you can do that straight away
but you've got to be very careful with
your actual numbers there